i'm kennedy i'm bill hemmer i'm sandra
smith and this is the fox news rundown
friday february 11 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal for years members of congress
and presidents have promised to focus on
health care costs and bring down the
price of prescription drugs aside from
some executive orders it hasn't happened
some are getting impatient and taking
matters into their own hands at the end
of the day whether it's us or we force
others to push the price of drugs down
lower i'll feel good about myself we
speak with billionaire mark cuban
i'm chris foster millions of americans
are betting on the super bowl on sunday
more than ever live in states where
that's actually legal now this is not a
way to pay your mortgage uh or pay your
rent uh it's supposed to be fun you know
it is adult entertainment in the kind of
broadest in general sense
and i'm buck sexton i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
while president biden and former
president trump both signed executive
orders meant to lower prescription drug
costs the key to really changing pricing
requires legislation thursday in
virginia president biden pushed his
build back better act now stalled in the
senate which includes provisions meant
to address drug costs we're now in a
position where we can cap co-pays
for insulin
at 35 dollars a month
it's still a staggering profit three and
a half times what it costs to produce
the drug
you can do that with the stroke of a we
can do that with a stroke of a pen
the proposal within build back better
would allow medicare to negotiate drug
costs the president said it is currently
the only thing medicare cannot negotiate
drug prices were a focus of former
president trump's as well he talked
about it on the campaign trail and
proudly stated that pharmaceutical
companies did not like him very much in
case after case our citizens pay
massively higher prices and other
nations pay for the same exact pill he
signed executive orders relating to drug
costs including one that attempted to
have medicare pay no more for drugs than
other countries pay with similar per
capita gdp to ours both trump and biden
have signed similar orders allowing for
the importation of drugs from other
countries like canada where many drugs
are often cheaper but again the pressure
is on congress to do something here a
kaiser family foundation poll last year
found more than 80 percent of americans
support letting medicare negotiate drug
prices including 95 percent of democrats
and 71 percent of republicans
some are done waiting for an executive
order to really do the trick or for
congress to act
so if you go to costplus drugs.com
our goal is to sell initially generic
drugs at the lowest price possible
that's it that's our mission mark cuban
is a billionaire owner of the dallas
mavericks and he's now running a
prescription drug company if you go and
you find your drug there you'll see what
we pay for the drug you know let's just
say for the sake of example it's ten
dollars then we'll add fifteen percent
or a dollar fifty so a total of eleven
fifty then we'll add three dollars for
the pharmacy fee for the the pharmacy
we're working with to fill the
prescription and five dollars for
shipping and that's it
how disruptive
do you think this could be i imagine you
hope it will be very disruptive but give
me the i guess give me more
it's too early to tell but effectively
you know the entire pharmaceutical
industry how we distribute um
prescriptions is very disturbed right
it's very obvious there's it's a mess
right and it's a mess because
the the pharmacy these companies called
pharmacy benefit managers they kind of
act as the bouncer at a high-end club
who charges you a cover charge to get in
but then also not only they charge you a
cover charge to get in they also go to
the liquor companies and say if you want
to sell liquor in this club
you gotta spiff me you've got to pay me
a rebate now the same thing applies with
pharmacy benefit managers and insurance
companies
they say to the manufacturers you have
to give me a low price but on top of
that if you want me to make sure that
this insurance company will reimburse
their patients for your drug you have to
pay me a rebate because of all that and
because of that complexity that's what
jacks up the price of drugs so high even
when the manufacturer's cost and what
the manufacturers sell them for is
relatively low
yeah i think we in america have this
notion of pharmaceutical companies and
insurance companies being sort of the
the beneficiaries right of all the cash
but um
the pharmacy benefit management system
there are studies that have shown that
certainly their profits have soared in
recent years um how much do you have a
metric
of comparing your pharmacist fee
to to this existing model
here's what's really crazy because
so many of the pharmacy benefit managers
and some of their partners are able to
go out there and acquire customers you
know because there's a pharmacy on every
corner and i actually feel bad for the
independent pharmacies because what's
ended up happening
is that the pharmacy benefit managers or
whoever they're representing often will
charge the pharmacy
a fee
for sending them the prescription
so if you have a prescription for
whatever drug it may be
and you get it through a pharmacy
benefit manager client it could be
someone who advertises online it could
be an insurance company whatever it may
be they then go to a variety of
pharmacies in your area and basically
have said look if you want this business
you're going to have to pay us
not that we're paying you so we kind of
turn that side of the model upside down
so that when we you know we work with a
company called troop hill who's our
pharmacy and so rather than charging
them for the the business we send we
actually pay them three dollars per
transaction
got it
um mark are you when you negotiate with
the pharmaceutical company are you
getting the drugs
for a cheaper rate than maybe like a
another pharmacy are you negotiating in
that style or it's a flashlight no not
yet
yeah not yet i mean we're probably
playing a tiny bit more in some cases
we're paying the same but because we're
not paying that bounce or the cover
charge and because actually when asking
for a cover charge back we're able to
not have all that overhead plus we don't
deal with insurance companies insurance
companies really dealing with them
escalates the cost of doing these
transactions significantly and so
because we don't do that and pretty much
everybody else does
then we're able to sell at the low low
prices that we do
i was gonna say taking insurance
companies out you you know some people
think well if i can't use my insurance
it's going to cost me more
except
when your copay turns out to be higher
than the cost of buying it at
costplusdrugs.com
got it
briefly can you highlight any examples
on drug savings at this stage
and i don't have the top of my head
because i'm not in my regular office
but if you just go on cosplusdrugs.com
we'll give you examples of the retail
price and to be candid there's you know
if you really work hard not even
sometimes not even really hard you can
find cheaper prices than the retail
prices but you're going to be very hard
pressed to find anybody who offers
the prices as low as we do without
charging a membership fee but we don't
have any of that there's there's no cost
to join you just go to costplus
drugs.com you know if you can look to
see what your drug is you can compare
the price you're paying to what we
charge and if you sign up it's free and
we will we will continue to add drugs
and you know we're a little over a
hundred now we hope to be more than a
thousand hopefully two thousand by year
end and on top of that as our um
quantities grow we expect our pricing
our costs to go down and if our costs go
down then the price we sell them for
goes down as well and so our hope is at
least once a month if not more often
we'll be able to do a release saying
okay these drugs have gone down in price
for our customers ah
mark tell me why you're you're getting
into this we we associate you with hey
how much money can i make out of this
is this something that you can make
money on is this a profitable venture
for you
i wouldn't say it's profitable but it
should at least be break even um if i
ran it so that we weren't trying to
add more drugs or trying to um
do our own manufacturing then yeah even
a cost plus 15 it would be profitable
but that's not what we're trying to do
we're registered as a pbc
a primary benefit corporation so the
rules are a little bit different there
that you know the goal is not to just
make as much money as possible and you
know my mission really is to disrupt the
pharmaceutical industry and at the end
of the day whether it's us or we force
others to push the price of drugs down
lower i'll feel good about myself you
know i've got money my next dollar isn't
going to change my life but all the
emails and all the the social media
posts that we're already seeing and
we've only opened you know we've been
working on this more than three years
but we just opened january 19th and
there are so many posts out there saying
you changed my life or i can finally
afford my medication and you know where
i was having to make the hardest choices
ever on you know which medication it may
or may not be able to buy or how i had
to ration it
just that alone i mean money can't buy
that that's just you know
that gives you the good feelings right
wow
i have three more questions for you and
they are not related to your to to this
venture okay we'll see if i can answer
them
you can um i want your thoughts on nfts
non-fungible tokens for listeners who
don't know twitter's former ceo had his
first tweet for example turned into an
nft it sold for about three million and
i was reading
um nft sort of brought you more heavily
into the crypto space and i was reading
mostly
that it's mostly due to the ability to
make royalties off them i'm
still trying to learn about this the
husband is obsessed because he's an
artist can you explain
can you explain more about why you're
into nfts and the potential profit you
see with them
okay so there's two questions there why
i get into it i'm a tech guy right so to
me an nft is just an example of
something called a smart contract and
royalties
being connected to any nft you create so
that's the technical side we don't need
to go there but the simplest answer is
it's a digital collectible
anybody who's ever traded a baseball
card or any type basketball card
whatever it may be it's just a piece of
cardboard with a picture yet we assign
value to it because there's memories
associated with it um or there's a
collectibility or speculation associated
with it because somebody may want to pay
more than what you paid for it nfts are
no different it's the same with art you
know all of us have looked at a piece of
art then heard the pricing and went oh
my goodness why is it that much you know
my six-year-old could paint like that
and you know beauty's in the eye of
beholders and it's the same with um nfts
now what makes it a little bit more
interesting
as an nft is because it's associated
with the blockchain transaction
the the provenance the history of the
ownership of that digital collectible is
available for anybody to see
and it's non-fungible meaning it can
never be changed so if we took a
screenshot of this this interview we're
doing and then we went through a process
called minting which is what turns it
into an nft
it also would be at the same time
written to the blockchain and then
anytime it was sold in the future you
would see the history of each and every
transaction which really is is kind of
good because it makes fraud a little bit
more difficult so there's a little bit
different type of protection for an nft
in its collectibles market now that's
just collectibles
we could go in i could talk for days
about the business applications but
that'll give you a good understanding
about why the husband is like or anybody
for that matter is excited about it
because if you like to collect things
then nfts are easy
that's so interesting um we talked to
you mark at the beginning of the
pandemic i'm sure you remember our
riveting discussion i don't think i
don't think any of us really thought it
was going to last this long but you were
among those who were very hopeful
about like sort of a new kind of economy
after we emerged more entrepreneurs i
think you ended up being
correct in that the economy did really
change we've had this great resignation
increased wages though not enough to
keep pace with the inflation we're
seeing and some supply chain issues what
is your
next
i guess economic prediction you know
where are we going next
i mean if i were that smart
i would just do something about it right
but you know as i said when we talked
before there
were changes and people took the time
and took advantage of the stimulus
programs to go out on their own and
create their own companies and we've
seen entrepreneurship and the formation
of new
companies just explode maybe too strong
but grow significantly and i think
that's great for the company when the
more people you have experimenting with
entrepreneurship and starting companies
the more people that will experience the
american dream and that's people of all
walks of life i mean you know now that
we're working from home people have a
little bit more time to no matter where
you live no matter what your
circumstances to at least try
so i think all those things together you
know really create a strong base for the
economy and i'm optimistic going forward
mark cuban thank you so much for your
time
thank you so much i really enjoyed it
[Music]
this is buck sexton with your fox news
commentary coming up
the super bowl comes with traditions
like food the commercials the halftime
show and of course gambling maybe it's a
few bucks in an office pool or bedding
with friends the texas furniture
salesman jim mattress mac mcinvale bet
4.4 million dollars on the underdog
bengals he'll get 7.7 million if they
win to pay back customers who bought
furniture under a promotion where it's
free if cincinnati wins he says his wife
thinks he has a gambling problem she
regrets my gambling but i love to
promote love to make customers happy and
when they have a rooting interest in the
big game it makes the game more exciting
as they sit on their new furniture they
bought from gallery furniture and cheer
the bengals on to victory he drove to
louisiana to make his bet online since
that's legal there now and more sports
betting in america now is legal look the
super bowl is the premier sporting event
in america and it will be again this
year bill miller is president and ceo of
the american gaming association our
research shows that we'll it'll be about
31.4 million american adults will bet on
the super bowl this year
and that's up about uh 10 million from
the year before wow does that number
include
you know office pools and
you know buying a box at a bar and stuff
like that or is that all uh you know
legal gambling
um it's both um you know it it's
probably half and half you know uh
retail and online sports betting and
then kind of uh the other half of the 31
is probably you know casually betting
with friends squares and that sort of
thing yeah i assume the increase is all
or almost all
the retail and online sports look it
wasn't that long ago bill that the pro
sports leagues especially the ncaa were
opposed to legalize sports books on this
scale they said look there's a danger to
live integrity what happens if some kid
you know gets thrown a couple bucks to
to miss a free throw to help
somebody beat the spread on a game and
now everybody's all in uh every ad i
mean you're seeing sports books in pro
arenas now are you surprised at how fast
it turned and why did it turn so fast um
look i've spent most of my life either
in government or lobbying government and
advising government and quite frankly
i've never seen anything move as quickly
as this
and i think it's been for you know
two really important reasons number one
the supreme court um back in may of 2018
uh invalidated what was in essence a
monopoly that nevada had where it was
the only place in america where you
could legally bet on sports now nobody
is naive enough to think that people
didn't bet on sports back before may of
2018 but they didn't have a legal option
and so
what happened was in state capitals all
over the country
legislators and politicians recognized
that their constituents were betting on
sports um and it would be preferable to
give them a legal option and that that
legal option provided consumer safety it
provided tax revenue created jobs
and many of these states had already
seen the benefits of gaming
in their states via casinos and others
and so it was
that the uptake was really quick and
really fast
now the
you know some of the leagues teams etc
kind of had a
rather cautious um i'll use that word
cautious uh approach to
the you know um the increased
opportunities as it relates to gaming
and you know some kind of talked about
whether you know it hurt the integrity
of the game and
i think our argument was and has been
the dominant and the pers
pervasive argument that has won out in
all of these state capitals and that is
that
people have been betting let's create
some protections for the consumer and
strengthen the integrity of the games
since the last super bowl the number of
states with legal sports gambling up and
running has gone from 20 to 30 plus
washington dc online sports books are
operating in 19 states that means a lot
of people who've never gambled on sports
before might be giving it a shot and
could end up with a gambling problem as
people think about you know betting on
um the super bowl or betting on march
madness when we when we'll get up to
that in in not that long
is that this is not a way to pay your
mortgage or pay your rent uh it's
supposed to be fun it is
it is intended for you know it is adult
entertainment in the kind of broadest in
general sense and so
it should be social
with your friends it should be something
that you think about from the
perspective of making sure that you have
a budget
and
and you stick to it and i think that um
if you if you use those as your kind of
guiding principles around betting on on
the super bowl or really you know when
we get into march madness i think you'll
i think you'll you'll you'll be able to
have fun with this and not put yourself
in a position where um um
you know
financially it becomes uh challenging
yeah i mean i guess the healthiest way
to look at it is um you know consider it
entertaining entertainment money spent
consider going to lose every bet you
make but
if you win you win that's great you you
get an endorphin hit and you get a
little money in your wallet
that's right i'm you know that it is
incredibly exciting that we're able to
do this
um
under a frame that allows for it to be
done with consumer protections
it's done with legal and oversight
and we have seen that
the leagues and teams and arenas all
across the country kind of come around
to this idea that
fan engagement
sports betting adds to that and but it
should add to it in a fun way in a
social way where you get a thrill if you
win but you shouldn't assume that this
is going to be a way that you're going
to uh augment your 401k
uh
you know sports fans just want to watch
the game i've heard at least anecdotally
man i'm sick of
i'm sick of seeing jb smoove trying to
get me to sign up for caesars i'm sick
of all the commercials um
there's a lot of players in this
industry throwing a lot of money at this
and also the big bonuses like you can
just if you sign up now at an online
casino and online sports book in many
cases they'll match your deposit as long
as you you know promise to gamble it uh
is the bubble gonna burst at some point
or the profit's so big
that they can afford to just throw money
at all of it
um
look it's this is an entirely new
industry right it's in it well it's an
entirely new industry a new legal
industry and so advertising to kind of
uh
move people from the illegal market into
the legal market is a really positive
thing
now you know advertising saturation and
kind of the the the repetitiveness of it
is part of
migrating those sports bettors that
we're betting on sports just betting on
sports illegally
is is something that will take some time
but it will the market will rationalize
and i think we'll see some
seasons seasonality around the start of
the nfl season or
maybe the playoffs march madness
but we've already seen
a plateauing and decrease in the amount
of ads really since the third or fourth
week of the nfl season so
you know the other really important
element to
what
the frequency and the number of ads and
promotions that are given are going to
be the shareholders because you know at
least for these publicly traded
companies
they've got to go and defend what it you
know what their advertising and and
customer recruitment strategies are
and the market you know the stock market
particularly will
kind of punish those that they believe
are not acting in a way that
is in alignment with their shareholder
views so i think that again it's it's
it's a new market we're kind of still
working our way through it
um my belief is that we've probably
already peaked in terms of you know that
the frequency the number
of sports betting ads
but you know i've got two little kids
and you know they want to be able to you
know play on uh you know bet on sports
themselves and we know that you know at
nine and eight that's that's not
appropriate and so um
i i'm i'm confident that we are going to
get to a place where this market
rationalizes itself from an advertising
perspective but it really is important
to remember
why that advertising's taken place it's
in order to move all of these people
from the illegal market into the legal
market where there are consumer
protections and that those consumers who
have been betting
actually didn't have any consumer
protections um and so ultimately i think
that's a really positive thing
especially with something like the super
bowl you can bet
from the coin flip to what color
gatorade gets tossed on the coach
how is there an effort
of the this is a weird example but let's
see what a prop bank on the length of
the national anthem it's going to go
over or under a certain amount of time
is there an effort to eliminate bets
like that that actually can be
determined by a human being
where it's a predetermined outcome
well think about it that there are many
things that are prop bets within it
within the whistle to whistle that are
determined by human beings right now uh
going to some of these goofier uh prop
bets like uh you know the length of the
length of the
national anthem or the color of the
gatorade
those are not bets that legal operators
are going to offer
um
and
and so the again going back to what we
talked about a little while ago you know
those regulators those boards they they
determine what are the acceptable bets
that a legal operator can
put out for the public the ceo and
president of the american gaming
association bill miller bill thanks for
coming on today
oh thank you so much and uh happy to
come on anytime
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information on your
time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts subscribe to this
podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a trip to the super bowl is pretty
memorable not just for the teams that
play in it but the fans that go to see
the game
three friends who have attended every
super bowl are going again this year for
what they say will probably be their
final trip as a group
all three men are in their 80s and they
haven't missed a single one since going
to the first afl nfl world championship
game 55 years ago
don crisman is 85 and lives in maine and
says this is his last game gregory eaton
who lives in michigan is 82 and wants to
keep attending but said his health
concerns could be an issue
and tom henschel who's 80 wants to make
it to the 2026 super bowl don and tom
first met at the 1983 super bowl and
eaton met them in the mid-2010s
this year's game is special because
they'll be able to sit together again
last year at the super bowl in tampa
they were several rows apart because of
the pandemic
gregory who's rooting for the los
angeles rams says he paid about 2
dollars for his seat which is about four
hundred times more than the cost of the
cheap seats in nineteen sixty seven
as for why they've done this year after
year he says we just love football the
three friends use the time to reminisce
and spend time together with this year's
trip promising to be a little more
special than the rest tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind defund police is
arguably the most destructive idiotic
political slogan in living memory no
serious person certainly no elected
leader worthy of any respect should have
ever supported it in practice or
principle but many democrats did and
there must be accountability for such
insanity thousands of lives including a
record number of cops have been lost to
increased criminal violence because the
left told lies about law enforcement
when it suited their politics the
causation of the national crime wave is
straightforward after the killing of
george floyd in may 2020 the black lives
matter movement mobilized behind the
defund police slogan the mainstream
democrat party cynically promoted this
anti-police narrative to rally their
base in an election year they pandered
to blm because anything was justified in
their minds to stop president donald
trump including widespread riots and
anarchy in american cities now the
enduring results of that madness are in
over 18 months since the rise of blm
predictably the data tells an appalling
tale the last year and a half in america
has been a bloodbath of violent crime
murders in almost two dozen u.s cities
were up five percent in 2021 after
already being up 44 in 2020 as compared
to 2019 according to an analysis by the
council on criminal justice and in the
middle of it all are police officers
police suffered more casualties
nationwide 73 killed in the line of duty
in 2021 than they have in almost three
decades last month 30 police officers
were shot seven so far this year in nyc
alone this isn't a crime wave it's a
tsunami
how do we get here we can start where
the crime trend lines do the rise of the
blm movement in june of 2020 the
foundational lie of blm that police are
murdering young black men systematically
without consequence out of racism in
large numbers created a political panic
that stretched deep inside our
institutions of law and order the
democrats rhetoric of criminal justice
reform spiraled into recklessly soft on
crime policies defund police led some
jurisdictions like austin texas to
dramatically cut back resources to cops
and then the city hit an all-time murder
record for 2021. in portland oregon
police funding was cut and then the city
decided after over a thousand shootings
in 2021 to officially refund police and
add an extra 5 million on top of that
with the political cover of blm and the
connivance of the democrat party
so-called progressive prosecutors felt
empowered to seek absurdly weak
sentences even for violent career
criminals state legislatures in places
like new york passed bail reform laws
that made sure violent felons would be
back out on the streets the same day in
many cases within a few hours of
offending in san francisco where thefts
of under 950 are treated as a simple
misdemeanor that requires no arrest
shoplifting and other crimes skyrocketed
even more than the previous years of
unbridled lawlessness in the bay area
the american people have seen the
results of the blm democrat narrative it
made everything worse for everyone
americans are now less safe on the
streets in their cars and homes
minorities living in high crime areas
suffer disproportionately from the
massive surge in violent crimes and
police have taken the brunt of an
emboldened criminal element in our
society in many cases with their lives
enough blm's anti-police rhetoric is
reckless our law enforcement officers
are not racists nor are our criminal
justice laws black lives matter not only
failed to address systemic inequality in
a meaningful way it pushed falsehoods
that hurt all americans many people lost
their property security and even their
lives because of big lies about criminal
justice from the left the democrat party
needs to be held to account for its role
in this an electoral annihilation this
fall would be a good start and it would
make us all safer this is buck sexton
co-host of the clay travis and buck
sexton show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes